hey I'm Rob cisternino and I'm here with
one of these Survivor winners a war that
was part of that big jury that voted for
the winner last night the great legend
of survivor Ethan Zohn Ethan how are you
doing I am doing fantastic how you doing
yeah I'm so excited what a finale last
night it was Tony of La chose who became
the second two-time winner of Survivor
what was your reaction in the real time
to being a part of that big jury it was
definitely an experience I was torn the
entire time to go with Tony to go with
Natalie I ended up voting for Natalie
and I we can get into that if you want
to hear about my rationale sure but yeah
so I had I never met Tony I still
haven't met him in person I mean after
the event obviously I met him but I
never met I never shook his hand I never
talked to him I never met him I didn't
know anything about him everything I
knew about Tony came from seeing him at
tribal council and then what people
would tell me when they came to the edge
which may or may not be true however I
lived with Natalie for 30 days on the
edge of extinction so obviously I
developed that personal relationship I
saw how she just destroyed me and
everyone else on the edge and obviously
when she you know played her self back
into the game I was just so torn because
you know my brain and strategy and in
Survivor purest side of me was saying
Tony like he played an incredible game
he crushed it he did everything he
possibly could to win but on the flip
side is like Natalie did the best she
could possibly do on the edge of
extinction and so that was kind of where
my brain was going but it was a it was a
tough decision for me to come to that to
come to that conclusion and for you this
is the first time that you were a part
of the jury was that a weird experience
for you it was a weird experience to be
part of the jury for the first time in
the sense that I mean I think the jury
experience on the edge' extinctions a
little bit different in general yeah
then the traditional jury's everyone's
familiar with
but I felt it was good because I wanted
to have a say in the game I wanted to
have an impact in the game it was clear
I didn't really have an impact to the
game based on my actual time in the game
so you know yeah I was there I suffered
I played my hardest I wanted to have
some small piece of deciding who would
win the grand prize of two million
dollars to be the champion was there one
person on the jury that was really a
champion for Tony that was pushing
people to hey come on everybody let's
vote for Tony um I think there was a lot
of people that were pushing for Tony and
that's a whole nother thing I'd never
been part of a jury never been part of a
jury and I never a part of an experience
where people could talk and try to
influence others decisions whether that
was legal or not legal I have no idea
but from my experience you know I was
voted off on Survivor Allstars and from
my experience hearing that's right I
forgot you even on the show a lot of
people do you were my favorite player
but for my from what I know that you
weren't allowed to talk to people you
weren't allowed to in job the juries at
Ponderosa and that completely happened
this time so I was like whoa people are
campaigning for people still in the game
which was interesting you know how about
I know the tribal council ends up
getting cut down for the show was it
more heated in real life because it
seemed like that the tribe that the jury
for the most part was very positive with
this group of three I in general I would
say it was a positive jury there were a
little a few questions that were a
little bit you know just inflict a
little bit of pain a couple regretful
situations people want a little bit
payback for what they got burned a
little bit but in general I think it was
a decent Tribal Council
I was also torrential downpour which
everyone was freezing you know it was
going on for a really long time and so
that was part of it as well I think
everyone just wanted to speed it up a
little bit can you talk a little bit
about the thing that Boston Rob
mentioned where
Nataly it seemed like that she had been
fallen had a falling out with a bunch of
the old school players on the edge of
extinction during that last week because
that was the surprise when that came up
in the final Tribal Council
sure I think that I personally didn't
witness that situation I was close with
Natalie I continued I had a same
relationship with her from start to
finish
however when the newest players arrived
like a Sophie of Kim Natalie had never
met them and she I think she felt she
needed to start to get to know them a
little bit better if she's gonna manage
the jury for when she did get back in
the game there was no doubt in her mind
that she was getting back up again like
that is something I see now watching the
show and hide yeah because and don't
forget I'd though I had no idea what was
going on in the edge for most of the
time I had no idea she was finding clues
and sending money back into him I would
have conversations with her saying oh my
god - no one knows I actually had a
conversation saying they think the edge
is sending them clues and fire tokens
how and she looked at me like yeah it's
crazy so like she was running the game
kept it a complete secret until kind of
the poverty Tyson thing happened and
then it's not blew up out of the water
and everyone knew that oh my god
and then when she went through a resume
she won every challenge on the edge
where she had a hand in every single
possible moment you could win something
on the edge she did it she's in the
first or second that is impressive in my
mind Rob also said when he voted for
Tony
he said that Natalie you didn't do
enough if Natalie would have gone and
made the fire against Tony and
potentially knocked Tony out of the game
do you think that that would have been
the difference for the jury I do
I think if Natalie had sacrificed
herself you know and went against Tony
in one I think she wins the game in that
situation yeah there was a lot of talk
on the edge of extinction about season
38 where a guy by the name of Chris
voted off 3rd or 4th came back into the
game and won and so she knew that and
she knew how we were feeling in our mind
Tony she was
was telling the truth tony was the clear
choice for a lot of the folks on the
edge um so she knew going into it that
she would have to do something big in
order to win the game and taking out
Tony probably was the biggest thing you
could have done to secure yourself a
spot in the final three and when
Michelle ended up getting no votes in
the final three do you feel like that if
it was a different season that was not
winners at war that she would have
gotten more consideration from the jury
I do I feel Michelle really came alive
towards the last few episodes and I was
impressed with how her decision-making
you know made sense you know I think
people were probably a little bit you
know if you had to compare Michelle to
Tony and Natalie you know the appearance
of how she played the game didn't come
across as strong as those two so
therefore I can understand how she
didn't get any votes but in a normal
game I think she would have gotten a lot
of votes I think she did really well she
played the best game she could have
played with the position that she was in
you know she's not necessarily a
challenge beast she's not the one she
wasn't able to work herself into an
alliance where she was making the
decisions from from my experience and
from what I witnessed watching the show
so I think she was just she did the best
she could did I we are all very
impressed that she made it that far and
deservedly so after crushing some of
those puzzles winning immunity
I was I was truly impressed and I see I
thought her tribal council performance
was better than the other two in terms
of how she uh geared her story and
revealed the decisions she made to get
her where she was today I thought you
did a really really strong job at tribal
council how about if Sarah got into the
final three there been any talk on the
edge of extinction if Sarah might have
been able to beat Tony there was a
little talk and in my experience I think
she would have gotten a couple votes
maybe like a Kim and a Sophie maybe a
Denise but I think Tony against Sarah
Tony would have won from our experience
we thought Tony was running the show and
Sarah was just kind of helping that
happened you know it seemed like it was
a different scenario maybe as the
vale but that was our experience but we
figured out if sara wins the final for
fire-making and she's there with
Michelle and Natalie does she win there
no I think natalie when's that Wow I
think so I don't know that's a guy I
would have to kind of think through that
a little bit more I would have voted for
Natalie still obviously I think a lot of
the edge people would have voted for
Natalie over Sara but it could add that
one challenge probably would have
changed a lot of minds at that moment
you know Sara beat Tony took the rock
took him out I think that would have
made a lot more difficult decisions for
some of us I do think if Natalie you
know I I think if she went up against
Tony and beat Tony she wins if she went
up and loss against Tony she lost but
she lost anyway so you know she had to
come across with a giant move although
she crushed it when she got back in
there I don't think the only mistake she
made was that mistake and I don't think
it was a big mistake
but Tony made no mistakes you know yeah
so a lot of the people at home who
watched the show I don't love the edge
of extinction and feel like hey that we
didn't like it when Chris won the edge
of extinction but we've never been to
the edge of extinction
how did going there change your view on
whether or not a person from the edge
should be the winner of a season of
Survivor it changed my decision in the
sense that the edge is the part of the
game during this season these are the
rules this is the hand we were given and
you need to you need to play within the
rules of the game at that time so in
that sense it's all fair game to me as a
survivor purist
the entire concept of the game of
Survivor is you can't get voted out
right and that didn't happen for Natalie
I mean she got voted out and so I think
that's a big part of it and and you know
she wasn't able to achieve some of the
biggest moments in the show because she
wasn't really in the show so I
completely see both sides the purist
side of me says Tony's the winner my
heart tells me Natalie's the winner but
living on that living on the edge
that place is hardcore you know it's all
about
personal relationships which is my game
that's all I'm good at he's kind of
hanging out and talking to people but I
feel she did an incredible job over
there she couldn't have done any better
I guess maybe they end with Rob and
those folks but other than that I think
she played a flawless game even one of
the things that we saw last night was
that Ben seemingly gave up his spot in
the game so that Sarah could advance he
gave her permission to vote him out how
did you receive that when you heard that
story at the edge of extinction
well we didn't hear that story until we
got to Ponderosa yeah so I was surprised
I was surprised that Ben made that
choice you know watching it back it was
obviously an emotional moment they
shared that I thought was actually
beautiful how it how it came about
however you know the gamer in me she
kind of got a go as far as you can go
and I think I would have liked to see
you know been you know put in a hundred
percent effort having said that I think
he probably analyzed if he was in the
final three against Tony he would have
lost if he's the final three against
Sarah he would have lost if he's in the
final three against Natalie he probably
would have lost so in his mind in that
and Michelle had the you know the the
neck so I think he could do a good big
favor for a friend of his he could look
um you know make himself feel good about
that moment and leave with his head held
high and so I think it was kind of like
do I come and fulfill Thor there coming
forth to him it just didn't really
matter at that point of the game even
did you at any point consider leaving
the edge of extinction we saw you
talking with Parvati we saw you're
talking with your wife about how hard it
was there that was there any point where
you were saying like I think I might
just go and raise the sale to get out of
here yeah every day every single day
every second of every single day I was
thinking about it yeah I did
all the time you know um you know and
I'm gonna take one moment to get a
little like you know deep on you the
experience I had on the edge of
extinction completely kind of paralleled
my journey with cancer in the sense that
the edge of extinction is a life you're
living between life and death you're in
purgatory same with cancer you know on
the game of Survivor you got two shots
to get back in the game same with cancer
like if there's an experimental new drug
if there's like you know some way you
can cure yourself you got to take that
shot so I was feeling this vibe going on
where like I didn't I wouldn't want to
just give up and
give up against you know a health crisis
and I didn't want to give up against the
game of Survivor and you're tired and
you're hungry and you're thirsty you're
skinny you're not thinking correctly you
know you're sad you're lonely you're
away from everything you're comfortable
with you're depressed that's what it's
like out there and that's exactly the
same feeling you have when you're going
through cancer so like I was instantly
thrust back to this like PTSD post
cancer like the last time I felt like
that was when I was sick so I had a lot
of stuff going through my mind and so
the edge of extinction for me
emotionally spiritually was was crushing
traumatizing however I knew I just had
one more shot two more shots to get back
in the game and for me I just could not
give up I could not pull that flag I
could not bring myself to that I respect
the game too much I respect myself I did
a lot of work to get myself in my body
in my mind and my spirit ready to go
play again and I just wasn't wasn't
ready for it to be over and I didn't
want to give up are you officially
retired from Survivor now I'm officially
retired from surviving maybe I'll pull a
car in and maybe get a boat ride to like
you know or they could build a statue
okay I'll show up again but to play the
game um yeah yeah you're good I'm good
I'm good even so Tony becomes only the
second two-time winner of Survivor is
Tony now as the winner of winners at war
and two-time champion of the game is
Tony the greatest ever in your mind you
know yes I do think he is probably the
best player in Survivor I he beat a
pretty hardcore group of players having
said that like you put him in any other
season you know put him with another 19
other than winners she's just completely
different game you have no idea but at
this game he did the best I think he
proved himself he had the incredible
incredible game the most well-rounded
game if you think about it the only
thing you know one of the things we were
discussing about as a philosophy of why
natalie is deserved of the wind versus
Tony is like if you're looking at I get
back to this you're looking at this
season a survivor and everything that's
happening in the show the person that
experiences every moment in that show is
as deserved
Tony never went to the edge of
extinction mm-hmm all right that is part
of the game so like maybe in order to be
the best player you have to experience
the edge of extinction and play back in
and that proves how good of player you
are not many people get voted out and
play their way back in and do well so
when he didn't do it it wasn't alright
so there's like there's two sides of the
coin right you know Tyson and Rob have
both clearly said that they felt even
going into this that they knew in order
to win this game they would have to be
voted out and play their way back in
that was the only way they would have
won and I agree with that yeah for me I
think that the the game that Tony played
this season was just so impressive where
that Tony I didn't know that he could
play a game like this that I thought
that maybe his uh his up side had
already been exposed especially after he
came back in Survivor game changers and
for him to come back with a sense of
patience that he did where he was able
to wait out the right point to start
going full crazy
Tony mode I just didn't think that he
was capable of that so I'm just so so
super impressed with what he did and I
think that this game that he put on here
in winners at war might be the most
complete game that we've ever seen in
history of the show yeah I agree with
you on that against incredible
competition exactly you're absolutely
right absolutely right you know yeah
there's no way to say it I know other
way to say it you are absolutely right I
feel he played an incredible game and
very hard to beat very old Ethan thank
you so much for coming on and talking
about some winners at war and about your
experience with us today well thanks for
having me man always a pleasure to talk
to you